we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P uh this some of
you might like this the San Antonio
troll has come out of the woodwork and
he is once again slamming me for things
I never said and that I don't believe we
have been hearing from the San Antonio
troll for years and one of the Hallmarks
of the calls to our voicemail number
from the San Antonio troll is that he
will slam me and criticize me for things
that he must have either made up
altogether
uh or heard on a different show because
they don't reflect in any way things
that I've said on this program this is
an exact uh example of that here the San
Antonio troll slams me for the things I
said and the things I believe about the
Rhonda santis Martha's Vineyard stun
um
he's just confused and for those of you
who listen to other Progressive shows
let me know if you can tell who he might
actually be talking about
Pac-Man it is the uh uh your dear old
friends and Senator troll yeah um I'm
from Texas and I saw you flip out about
this story where oh my God there's any
right here
wasn't this show I wasn't flipping out
at all
um
I think it's funny you're flipping out
and getting kind of a little triggered
and it's funny that they the you know
the great Rich wealthy people of Moses
Vineyard already deported these people
so it it's not a deportation when you go
to a different state first of all and
secondly as I've talked about earlier
Martha's Vineyard is a tiny island with
very few jobs and even fewer jobs off
season there's a few hotels and you know
a couple stop and shops there there's
very little to do so there's just no
jobs there for the Immigrant I mean this
whole concept of deportation is crazy
um and you and by the way
the last before today and this voicemail
was left over the weekend
I hadn't even talked about the
immigrants leaving Martha's Vineyard so
this couldn't possibly be about anything
I said but you've always been favorable
reporters
not not this show as many of you know
I have never been in favor of open
borders as I have said before we need a
path to citizenship for those who came
here as minors and are still here and
this is really their home we need
immigration reform the wall is pretty
dumb I have never been for open borders
in fact there are people in my audience
to my left who do want open borders and
I've said no countries are allowed to
have a border and to enforce it but
let's do it in a way that makes sense
this proves my point of liberalism you
to everything is the moral High ground
with you you are the you're morally oh
we should let everybody in we should
give this to everybody that's never been
something I've said Jesus nobody should
carry around Goods it's very easy to
take these holier than thou Physicians
when you live 2 000 miles away yeah not
positions I've taken but talk to
somebody who maybe has taken them it's
all Pac-Man two thousand miles away in
your big double-gated Community with
armed security guards front at the ready
it's very easy to say hey let everybody
into our borders yep okay so anyway I've
never said let everybody in very very
confused individual my here's my request
I am more than in it's not I'm willing
I'm interested in receiving critiques of
My Views being corrected I issue
Corrections all of that
but call in and talk to me about
something I've said that's my that's my
request all right we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad all of Puerto Rico is
without electricity as hurricane Fiona
has made landfall I hope
that Joe Biden's response to this
hurricane is going to be better than
that of Donald Trump during Trump's term
we're going to talk about it we are
going to talk about the special Master
assigned to review the documents taken
from Trump's Mar-A-Lago his name is
Raymond Deary we'll tell you all about
him and we are also going to talk about
Gavin Newsom the governor of California
challenging Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis to a debate after migrants were
sent to Massachusetts as we have
extensively covered all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show don't
miss it sign up at joinpakman.com and
I'll see you then